i want to jump to this first story which
uh look we we're going to get into
the census stuff for sure but we're
going to chill we're going to talk about
some
an article you wrote four years ago
melanie so we have this
from the new york post childish men are
to blame
for women having kids late in life i
wonder if that made men really angry
at men or at you but let just explain
what is this article about
so as we know generally the writer
doesn't actually write the headline so i
would just like to say it or add the
photo
i that was not the point of the piece
the point of the piece
is to say that pew research had new data
that found
that women are much more
focused on marriage and parenthood than
men are
and also more focused on career
than men are and women have to know
that they may not find the man that they
want to be with
as soon as they want to be with him and
that they need to consider
whether they want to you know look at
their fertility freeze their eggs
consider now these are not i haven't
frozen my eggs i didn't freeze my eggs
maybe they want to think about having a
baby on their own and save up for that
maybe they want to save up for ivf
so that was what the piece was about it
was never
about making men feel like they
are not worthy of women how did how did
how did that come about then how did
they
make your article about that because
because that's how
headlines work i mean is it because men
by by virtue of what you're saying they
conclude that
men aren't focused on family and career
enough so they're calling them childish
men
was it a dude editor who was like these
men are losers
no and i love my editor my editor is
amazing
no but some men
uh did certainly get upset in fact there
was one
that decided we needed like a talmudic
track
you know treaties on this was an
hour-long you know
opinion piece on how i was wrong even
though he was talking about the data
that is p
research data it did upset a lot of men
and that frankly upset me because i
actually love men and i love boys and
i'm a champion of men and boys
so and i don't think that men and boys
are
childish but i do think that
we have a problem in america whereby we
are so focused on girls and women
and their power and empowerment that
boys
and men kind of fall into the background
and i think that if we want
to enable women to have all that they
want we need to raise
boys and men up i don't know you you run
into trouble
when you start talking about this stuff
because even though right now
women are the majority of those
graduating college the narrative is
still that they're in the minority and
they're in the weaker position
shouldn't we start getting rid of these
women's programs and start propping up
men's programs to encourage
men to get i'm not a fan of college by
the way so this is not a you know an
apology or or me now supporting it no no
but just for the general context
shouldn't these
feminists be like oh we gotta support
the minority that's the men now
i you know i don't know that you have to
take anything away from girls
girls should be able to reach their
potential um
the problem is that we've forgotten boys
so yes girls in stem
science technology engineering and math
girls have to you know
get equity with boys and wonderful
fine not a problem with that the issue
is that boys are falling way behind in
literacy and we don't talk about that
by age six boys don't want to read with
their mommy anymore because they think
it's too girly
and um they don't want to read with the
family anymore because it's just not
something just not something that they
want to do and we
tend to again focus on girls in stem and
you know i'm a i'm
a toy industry expert i go to toy fair
every year and other toy events
and i remember i went to one once major
company
and they had dolls
fairy tale princess dolls and with them
came books so this princess had this
book and this princess
and then we went around and the the
more superhero characters were just
the the dolls where's the book
what do you mean there's no book with
these right this was your perfect
opportunity
to engage boys in literacy this is how
you do it
they want to read interestingly the
assumption is that because
boys are in the in the privileged
position they don't need help
and from that we've created a massive
disparity and now
right it's a fallacy it's absolutely a
fallacy well so then the issue i suppose
is
how are boys supposed to catch back up
to girls by going slower than they are
or at the same pace
wouldn't you need special programs and
wouldn't you then need to take away
programs from women
you know i'm not an educator so i don't
know what we
would need to take away from girls and
frankly i don't think we need to take
anything away from girls
i think what happens that boys
classrooms are set up for the way girls
learn sit still
listen take notes behave yourself don't
move around
boys need to move around you know but
then they get in trouble
and then they don't go back to class and
we've we've shrunk and recess
so boys aren't moving around when they
have the chance to move around
you know some kids even girls who have
you know some form of
add they need to move in order to learn
but we don't want kids to do that kids
learn through play
if you want to teach a child especially
a child zero to three
the best way to help them learn is to
help them play so
yes we need to help boys the way we do
it is to consider how they
learn and we need to
decide that boys have great potential
and if we believe in boys boys will
begin to believe in themselves
and if boys believe in themselves they
will then go to high school and if they
graduate high school if they graduate
high school they may go to college
if they want to and continue whatever it
is that they want to do or no go to call
not go to college whatever it is we just
need to give them the chance
what do we do about men now though
in terms of uh not being career driven
not having families yeah it's it's it's
sad
it's sincerely sad i'm sad for the boys
i'm sad for the men
um we have focused again so much on
women
that women have become more masculine
because we've been told generation x
millennials that you know anything boys
can do girls can do better
and you know in the 80s women i was
there
women were you know shoulder pads pant
suits we had to be masculine
and we're taught you know now more
recently you have to lean in
at work you know you have to take on the
way that men work the way that men
succeed in order to be equal
to them and so women became more
masculine and when you go on a date
women no no i
i'm okay no i'll pick the place oh no
let me play let me pay
and then you've got the men who don't
feel like they're contributing
anything and men want to feel like
they're needed like they're going to add
value to this fabulous woman's life
and women should start to
become a little more feminine and
understand
that femininity is not weakness that's
the issue we have the same thing of
men means oh they're scary and it's
toxic and toxic masculinity if they're a
man who behaves like a man
and if a woman behaves like a woman well
then she must be weak and fragile and
no no there is more power and femininity
in fact it's true i believe that
femininity is the one thing that can
bring a man to his knees
i've often uh mentioned that i think
feminism in today's day and age
is actually anti-femininity and
pro-masculinity
they like to go after what they call
toxic masculinity but
the way i break it down is we often hear
about like women must be ceos you know
we need more women doing that job and
that job
and while there are conversations about
having men stay at home with the kids
there's not a big demand for it the same
way so i i just i i'm
when did this happen where the the the
role of the
the maternal role just became irrelevant
to society and i don't mean completely
but to a greater deal
where now it's like no no the moms and
the dads should be in the workforce
and you know i don't know have child
care we should now what's really
fascinating to me is
they advocate for like government paid
health care i'm sorry child care
guaranteed child care
and it's like shouldn't the parents have
some system where they take care of
their kids
instead it's the maternal role is being
shoved down and women and men should
both be in the workforce
sure well so to be fair today with the
economy it happens that often enough
both parents need to work so there's
that too
so let's set that up but but is that a
result of
women in the workplace it could be you
double the supply of workers the demand
doesn't change
all of a sudden everyone's undercutting
each other's wages it could be
i'm not an economist and so i i don't
know that yeah i don't know they can
speak to it but it could be and i've
thought about that myself
um yeah it's true that this this idea
that
you know we don't have enough women ceos
higher management etc
it basically doesn't answer the the
question of whether or not women want
that
and it's not to say that women don't
want to reach their potential but their
potential isn't necessarily
in in the office and we've created this
narrative that women have to keep
fighting you know in the glass ceiling
and all this
not all women want that and that's okay
too in fact women have it pretty well
because a woman can go to college she
can get like a law degree
and you know get married and have a
child decide you know what
i'm i miss my kid every time i leave him
and i just want to be home and i want to
be mom and my husband is
can afford to to take care of us women
have that choice it's extraordinary
and yet we talk about women as if we're
sort of always limited by the
quote-unquote patriarchy
um i i why do you think they have that
choice i kind of feel like
right now guys aren't on average doing
as well i mean that's kind of the point
of the conversation they're not making
as much money they're not as driven i
think also
they're not as worried because they've
got all the time in the world as far as
they're concerned
so if a woman is you know doing well in
her career and she wants to then have a
you know family and have the husband
work she's got to contend with the fact
that there's probably not
as it's going to be hard to find a guy
for
for a few reasons one who's making
enough money to support the family
should she choose to opt out
who's going to be interested in a woman
who has a career even maybe the guy just
wants somebody
he wants a wife from the from the get-go
you also have the issue we have uh
our friend jack murphy comes to the show
quite a bit and he talks about how he
thinks guys should go for women 10 years
younger than them
who don't do any of this get someone
who's 22 marry her and just get a
housewife don't worry
about someone who's got a career so if
you have that mentality
how does a career woman then you know
have what you're describing so actually
maureen dowd
wrote about this not bad in new york
times in 2005.
how what men really want is their mother
and i agree
um and the problem is that
this generation were not their mother
gen x
was able to do things that our mothers
couldn't do
when you know women who graduated high
school in the 50s
you know if you look at their yearbook
you know what they were going to be was
teacher
nurse nun secretary
those are her choices if you're jewish
you only had three
so you know what what were these
women uh what were what was gen x
millennial women going to do once we
went to college we did everything right
you know there's no reason why we
shouldn't go to college no reason why we
shouldn't pay the rent
you know and then in terms of this
career woman thing there are no career
men
nobody accuses a man of of of
prioritizing
having a job over everything else in his
life
i mean i i always wanted to marry and
have children very much
so if i didn't have a career i mean
you'd basically be
you know paying my my way through life
as a taxpayer right because
i wouldn't be employed so you know women
have to
take care of themselves they have to
have agency but yeah um
so women do men do want their mother and
we're not their mothers which isn't to
say
that women aren't nurturing women don't
want to do this that women don't
want to nurture and take care of their
husbands and take care of their partners
i know most women do want that they also
though want to know that if they're
going to go through
childbirth which can be fatal
that there's a man there who's going to
be there and
certainly if god forbid shouldn't
survive that be there for the child be
able to pay for the child
and i mean this in an evolutionary
evolutionary way she may not be thinking
this literally
but yeah and so it is difficult and this
is why we have so many women
who are um the the new just newly
released data
a woman is the average age of marriage
for a woman is 27.
just 20 years ago it was 25.
wow i wonder if uh
as jordan jordan peterson mentions
enforced monogamy are you familiar with
the
the term it doesn't mean what i think a
lot of the feminists thought it
meant like the government would come and
like force women to marry some incel
dude or something like that
but you're talking about you know women
want to be secure they want to know that
if they're going to have a kid
they're going to be protected or safe or
have someone to take care of them isn't
that what marriage did
yeah that's certainly what marriage did
and that's what right the idea is that
we should have a culture
to you know encourage boys and men
to look to marriage that's that's a good
thing and now
they're not really encouraged to do that
and
and partly it's it is you know certainly
so
in terms of the college graduation so
858
of college graduates now brand new data
are women
42 men so and women tend to want to
marry a man even if she's got it higher
pretty you know
she never has to worry again about her
income she still wants to marry a man
who is
married who is making at least the same
amount of money
and of course there aren't enough men
who have that potential
and it thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you